позиції І ми тоді будемо обговорювати е
Значить тут треба буде подумати як це
діло робити тому що я наприклад би це
робив попредметно бо інакше буде дуже
довго робив попредметно е от якимось
чином паралельно ее тоді якщо е ви
узгодили з своїми тими робочими групами
з нашими академі своєї позиції розумієте
Тобто ми маємо дітей вчити щоб вони
дотримулисяказали свою точку зору
авторитет є авторитетом але ваша думка
теж є дуже важлива коли немає розходжень
але ви вважа на ширше обговорення я його
промодирую розумієте і тоді воно піде
тобто тобто от скажете ви посилаєтесь на
мене хобз Я сказав от що ми працюємо в
такій формі Тобто це не Ви придумали А
вам задали дав я маю право як заступник
Міністра задати такий план роботи а А
мені здається що він буде продуктивний
просто-напросто і він зніме не поб
непотрібні речі ее в певних недорозумінь
чи там я роджена тут так я роджена в
івано-франківській області якому районі
Вите звти Мої батьки Галицький район Ну
так снятнського агалицький Галицький
район так
Опілля Опілля знаємо такі Я з бурштина
то між
буршна справді Та ясно Добре Отже про
себе трошки значить я працюю Я закінчила
Львівський університет а які факульте
філологію
і я навіть не знала що ту так багато
Оксана справді
она якесьне слово та власне па Павло Та
я Павло пан Павло попросив мене трошки
розказати про себе Ну та щоб ми знали бо
ви то знаєте ми не знаємо Та Оксана
Також мабуть не дуже так багато
знає 10 років Я працювала тут в школі
дослужилася була до вищої
категорії і тоді в 2000 році в бурні
робили так ні я працювала в Трускавці
Мій чоловік з Трускавця Так я вийшла
заміж і в школі там працювала а в яких
роках коли ви поїхали в Канаду в 2000 в
2000 Так ясно Отже в 2000 році ми
виїхали
і тому що я рахувала Що вчительство то є
одне що я вмію добре робити Я так собі
думала то я вирішила в Канаді йти тою
стежкою так само стежка була дуже важка
мушу сказати тому
що по-перше треба було підтвердити всі
свої папери якраз ми приїхали на межі
того часу коли треба було здавати мовний
іспит потім
вони змушували ще добирати якісь курси і
таке інше і таке інше і трошки в освіті
Там Там є також свої проблеми багато
проблем і є моменти коли звільняють
вчителів скорочують а тоді трошки важче
Я якраз Попала не в такий найкращий час
ну мені зайняло досить довго бо так
сталося що я ще народила другу дитину
там то трошки відтягнуло мене в
процесі дістала я акредитацію тобто
дозвіл ліцензію вчити в Онтаріо в 2006
році а до того часу я працювала також в
освіті з дітьми Це був приватний дитячий
садочок український
а єдине що вони називали садочок це є
школа для маленьких для немовлят nursery
school так звани
А тобто я весь час починаючи і відразу
як ми приїхали в 2000му Я знайшла роботу
в суботній школі в суботній школі там не
потрібно було мати паперів ліцензії і
таке інше тобто проходив інтерв'ю як
Люди бачили що ти щось тямеш у світі там
в праці з дітьми то можна було дістати
роботу Отже починаючи з 2000 я вже
почала працювати в
Канаді з дітьми А тоді в
2006му діставши ліцензію почала
пробувати шукати роботу було не так дуже
легко ви знаєте імігранти хоч Канада Я
вже Оксані казала напевно
найсприятливіша країна для
імігрантів Але разом з тим в освіті
мігрантам нелегко знайти тому що
розумієте самі мають люди свій акцент і
і таке інше щоби прийти і вчити в
державній школі ну нелегко але мені
пощастило треба було волонтирити
волонтирити Треба було рік і система
канадської освіти побудована таким чином
що тепер особливо раніше було трошки
інакше А тепер що вчитель починає не як
е на постійній основі працювати це
називається supply teaching Тобто ти
приходиш ти ти є вчитель на на заміні
тебе
скажімо відділ освіти міський тому що я
живу в Торонто так і Toronto catholic
School Board в католицькому борді Я
працюю а найняв мене як supply teacher
тобто система дзвонить до тебе щовечора
і каже скажімо в тій і тій школі треба
вчителя на той день і ти вранці їдеш у
ту школу Ти приходиш не знаєш який клас
будь-який клас залежить від того взагалі
сеп вчитель на заміні це може бути
будь-який
клас
але от власне ви розумієте це є
надзвичайний момент тому що я я дуже
багато з того навчилася тому що коли ти
ходиш по різних школах бачи ти бачиш ме
тому що навіть як вчителя ж нема ти
приходиш з дітьми працюєш в тому класі
але ти бачиш матеріали на стінах якись
тобі лишає Вчитель повинен ніби
зобов'язаний залишити план на цілий день
Що ти робиш з дітьми
А і дивишся різні різні такі речі Тобто
ти вчишся і тільки після того як ти ще
проходиш одне
інтерв'ю той вчитель котрий вже на
заміні приходить ще одне інтерв'ю і його
вже ставлять на такий список що його
можуть найняти as a permanent teacher
так званий постійний на постійній основі
ти дістаєш постійну роботу це в Онтаріо
в інших провінціях система трошки
різнитьсяя але більш-менш одна бо
скажімо в альберті вони трошки інакше
мають в них вчителі взагалі на
контрактах працюють в нас ні в нас на
постійній основі але через отой сиплай і
тоді вже аж як з'являється позиція то
той вчитель котрий вже ходив на заміну в
мене так сталося що я була 4отири роки
на заміні але на заміні ти ще можеш
Можна ще я перепрошую я таксти бо тут
така трошки англійська
Калька на заміні можна ще дістати так
званий називається longterm
тобто на скажімо вчитель захворів якісь
проблеми на два місяці Так хтось зломав
ногу і тоді вони створюють
такий асаймен так званий що можна
працювати замість цього вчителя
місяць-два часом як вчителі йдуть на
в декретну відпустку рік навіть працюєш
Але ти знову ж таки ти все ж таки є отой
заміний вчитель на заміні пані Ірина в
чому от різниця між звичайними уроками І
компетентнісним підходом от ви і в
українській школі були бачили і там в
чому ця різниця Ну от різниця в чому
взагалі Ви розумієте в Канаді ніхто так
дуже не не наголошує що це є
компетентнісний підхід але вся система
вся система побудована на цьому бо я от
власне
переглядала ті всі речі якісь там різні
методики і таке інше вся система
побудована на тому І до речі ще вернусь
на секунду до до того на заміні тому що
ти як ходиш Ти бачиш скажімо я багато
навчилася от скажімо диференційований
підхід до навчання так і видно один
вчитель собі особливо в молодшій школі
організовує центри і діти вчаться по
центрах так і лий деньли довко столи
скажімо
є так п'ять центрів клас звичайно класна
кімната не виглядає як наша
традиційнакіките значить в нас в Онтаріо
починаючи від садочок трошки інакше в
нас садочок До речі належить до школи
для того отже є молодше передшкіл
починається школа з чотирьох років
молодше передшкілля тоді наступне старше
передшкілля а тоді починається перший
клас але всі вони належать до тої самої
Elementary school вони вже є студентами
учнями початкової
школи тепер змінили трошки тому що в
садочках вчителі вважають що забагато є
по дітей і на тих 30 дітей є двоє людей
працюючих є вчитель і
є то називається ear childh
той хто працює з вчителем А це в садочку
асистент в
садочку Отже
асистент він можна сказати асистент
вчителя Так але це суто вони навіть
вчаться тільки абсолютно на це на це
абревіатура і тому що вони вчаться
працювати тільки з маленькими дітьми
скажімо той хто має диплом ІС не може
йти працювати десь інде з іншими класами
тому що це є суто ІС а вони готують їх
для того щоб працювати з маленькими тоді
починається від першого класу до
третього класу дітей в класі не може
бути більше ніж 20 20 - це
максимум А чим це визначено визначено
тим що вчитель один не може приділити
увагу більше ніж 20 якимось нормативним
документом так нормативним документом
абсолютно Я думаю що це можна знайти
Десь навіть в onario
curcum в документах в Міністерства а
Можна вас запитати
ся до роботи ну от ви безкоштовно
працювали цілий рік Ну вам треба було
показати свою роботу ік А ви спеціально
там ніде не навчалися ви просто
показували свою роботу практично освіта
ваша тут Львів а далі Ні перед тим перед
тим От зараз я так трошки скачу я
перепрошую то ви мене вертайте значить
як як власне оцей момент переходу
значить в Онтаріо є інституція
називається Ontario College of Teachers
це є інституція котра видає ліцензію
вчителям без того що ти маєш оце occt
Ontario College of Teachers membership
ти не можеш працювати вчителем ота
Або можна працювати тільки в приватній
школі в приватній школі можна без
ліцензій без ліцензії так тому бо там
вже вирішують самі люди ті хто наймають
на роботу вони вирішують самі чи ти
пригодний для тої роботи чи ні А в
державній от те що все що залежить від
те що йде скажемо так зарплати вчителям
йдуть з грошей платників податків так
оце все має визначати Ontario College of
Teachers та інституція що видає ліцензію
далі для того От коли я подала свої
папери щоби дістати ту ліцензію Вони
сказали так твоя освіта є в порядку все
нормально але тобі в Онтаріо також Вони
вимагають якщо ти йдеш в Elementary
school то мусить бути Може бути тільки
один teachable subject так званий але
тому що я вчилася в Університеті і в
мене більше була скажімо на High School
спрямування то треба було мати два
предмети тому Я мусила йти добирати
брати курс місячний курс курс так званей
підвищення кваліфікації я би це сказала
в нас так виглядає це завжди при
університеті є при при кількох
університетах тих що вчать на вчителів
тому що щоб на вчителя вивчитися в
Канаді спочатку чотири роки бакалаврат
та як тут напевно так а тоді рік
залежить де рік часом в деяких
університетах півтора
А треба вчитися в teaching College Це
трошки інакше воно трошки плутається з
тим onario College of Teach але це дві
різні речі отой teaching College там де
тебе вчать бути вчителем і тільки після
того ти знов подаєшся в той Ontario
College of Teachers це не означає
автоматично що ти вже дістав ліцензію
Так ти подаєшся в той Ontario College of
Teachers і тоді тобі дають значить оцю
акредитацію Після того як я здала мовний
вимоги до іноземних іноземно вивчених
вчителів треба здати мовний екзамен так
званий ielts або е tofel напевногу чули
про це А і крім того показати що є
відповідні що ти відповідаєш тим
критеріям на основі котрих вони дають
тобі ліцензію тобто я добрала той курс
здала той мовний іспит і тому я дістала
то ctct акредитацію і тоді Таким чином
Вони мають скажімо якщо я порушила
якісь правила ті що встановлені Вони
мають я вам можу дати сайт Шкода що мій
комп'ютер не працює в мене там мій
паспорт відразу так я вам включу
інтернет я вам кажу так окей може
спробує
а і значить якщо я скажімо порушила
якісь певні правила ті які в них є
встановлені на тому сайті також можна
прочитати тоді вони мають право забрати
в мене ліцензію і якщо я не отримую то
ліцензії я відповідно не можу працювати
Давайте ми може більше про Про навчальні
план про ці речі бо то можна розказати
про канадську ви знаєте що я вам скажу
Так яс бо там велика зарплата зарплата
велика так зарплата починаючи молоді
вчителі починають скажімо 50 000 на рік
це не рахується дуже велика зарплати
вчитель четвертої категорії отримує
доларів 50 000 канадських тршки
менше 125 000 Ну 4000ні я вам скажу Так
десь 50 000 це буде 1042 американських
це на рік на рік без урахування податків
чи з вирахуванням ні вже потім ще потім
вираху вони тобі оце 50 тих тисяч
це як то брудними грошими нечисти а тоді
вже вчитель четвертої категорії отримує
90 000 і більше на Велика різниця меше
два рази але тому щоби дійти З першої до
четвертої категорії вчитель має Стимул
брати курси підвищення кваліфікації мати
якийсь досвід ну досвід ти працюєш Ти
маєш досвід очевидно але от підвищувати
свою
кваліфікацію пані Ірино ми зараз готуємо
велику реформу саме Ну школи початкової
для до 1 вересня Ми якраз такки амбітний
проект маємо розвантажити програми в
тому числі в нас нарікань багато на те
що в нас багато предметів для молодшої
школи забагато для такого віку і
заскладні вони за своїм змістом так чи
могли б нам трошки розказати про цей ну
дивіться у вас чотири предмети так от я
власне ви сказали що в принципі школа
починається з трьох років з чотирьох
років чи можете от по рівнях розказати
там з чотирьох років що вони вчать Да
коли починається Ну так в нашому
класичному розумінні початкова школа
скільки років вищо там по рівнях вчать
Скільки предметів ну в
середдочку вчила два роки то я можу вам
сказати про садочок Навіть трошки більше
в садочок щоб ви розуміли як ти працюєш
вчителем в садочку це те саме що ти
вчитель в п'ятому класі чи те саме що ти
вчитель в 12-му класі нема в зарплаті
мається на увазі багато людей з 12-го
класу кажуть що в житті би не робили те
що роблять вчителі в садочку бо це важко
бо треба мати спеціальний хист і
терпіння значить дитина приходить в
чотири роки тепер вони трошки змінили
тому що є називається playbased навчання
раніше було більш так академічно
пробували дітей щоб читати і писати і то
все і то все і п'яте десяте тепер ніби
йде розвантаження на playbased і так
зване що на основі гри на основі гри І
inquiry based що є inquiry based це є
таке навчання на запит так щоб вам
приблизно
розказати на хлопський розум так звано
скажімо дитина От бачить вчитель
спостерігає там шестеро дітей зібралися
в якому сь там в центрі і вони починають
А чому ж Сонечко світить і тоді вчитель
орієнтується і будує свій
наступний Unit чи як би це сказати
по-українськи там модуль модуль навчання
на основі от сонечко що про сонечко Ми
можемо навчитися і тоді можна значить
тим малесеньким що є вони називаються
молодше передшкілля JK ви розповідаєте
там включаєте тему колір тоді говорите
що тепло тоді якийсь елемент
е природничих наук в нас це просто
називається sнс так кажете от поставити
ручку воно нагріває значить є тепло що
що діється крім того можна діти також
вчаться там вже скажімо навесні рослинка
ростейце тобто більше спрямовано на оце
inquiry based А як вони пробують
витягнути з дітей ці питання
А вчитель ее впродовж цілого дня а часом
це робить асистент вчителя може поміж
дітей Ну вони скажімо там ходять і
спостерігають такі називається ancdotal
Notes вони роблять значить мають завжди
з собою оцей такий планшет і записують
от що би ти хотів А що би ти хотів сього
там навчитися І от діти кажуть і дітей
надзвичайно цікаві запитання часом
приходять такі що навіть не не міг би
собі уявити А чому А чому хмарки білі А
чому там небо сині щось таке і є от дуже
мені подобається та ідея ми ми Також
тільки недавно це буквально дуже нове
почали впроваджувати є така дошка і
скажімо на тій дошці вчитель там рукою
напише на листочку якесь запитання від
дитини і причепляє то питання і тоді
пробує якимось чином будувати своє от от
своє навчання те що воно їх вчить на
основі Того і в
кінці нам простіше тому що в нас є
скажімо кожен вчитель повинен мати iPad
або ще щось І оцінювання тоді тої дитини
йде для того щоб батьки бачили так на
батьківсь на в нас нема батьківських
зборів це є дуже такий радянський підхід
Я вам зараз розкажу трошки пізніше а але
батькам скажімо можна включити той самий
ipд і сказати от дитина навчилася бо
дитина ж в садочку не напише не скаже що
от я то знаю там чи таке от питаєшся іти
записуєш ту дитину дитина каже от
сонечко таке і таке а тому воно гріє бо
щось от такого плану з результатами
навчання от за результатами того
навчання що дитина мусить мати міти
розуміти це як якце кркм вкласти ви рік
провчили як хоче дитина але ви маєте
оцей Ні оце оце оцей кум це є другий Так
цеги кхай для друго класу ви можете Як
хочете робити але це вони мають знати
так А як ви це робите це є ваша абсо
абсолютну справу немає значення Ви маєте
методичні всякі речі тобто я можу йти за
якимись методичками як я не хочу творчо
робити мені якийсь тчегай дадуть і я то
буду урок за уроком то все пройду так і
то все пройдете І як воно перевіряється
за результатами навчання от за
результатами навчання як
перевіряється якщо ска скажімо брати про
бачите я не взяла От тепер ми говоримо
про це я собі згадала що можна було би в
нас є
спеціальнеort так званий Е для садочків
окремо воно цілком інакше виглядає там
діти не дістають ніяких ні оцінок ні
нічого хоча то вже є школа тільки там
скажімо
е не відповідає вимогам почав
відповідати вимогам і цілком відповідає
вимогам є такі три графи і там тільки
ставиться пташка навпроти кожної і там є
цілий перелік Ну
напевно Може 30 різних таких речей що
воно включає воно включає Насамперед
тому що садочок є перше що повинен
навчити садочок це навчити дитину
вчитися і бути в колективі так і творчо
висловлювати себе Але разом з з тим
поважати того хто дуже от дуже важливий
оцей емоційний розвиток дитини тому дуже
великий наголос робиться на те чи дитина
вміє поводитися чи вона вміє слухати в
колі бо в нас в садочку діти от заняття
проходить скажімо От коли є таке урок
називається так в наших в нашому
розумінні вчителька сидить скажімо часом
на підлозі часом на кріслі діти сидять
на килимчику так перед на кріселках
ніхто не сидить в Канаді такого нема В
канаді кріселка тільки вже в першому
класі коли треба писати а ну часом Ні
пра неправда як за столиком якась ручна
робота або щось щось писати треба то
діти сидять але коли йде оцей усний
виклад матеріалу не не виклад а от
спілкування з дітьми бо виклад то більше
вже для старшої школи діти сидять на
килимчику перед
вчителем і оттоді значить відбувається
оцей такий так званий урок тоді
переважно скажімо як ми вчимося про
якусь букву або ще щось діти після того
можуть піти
а на столику писати там або букву
вправляти і знову ж та якщо є різні
центри
е на в сенсорному центрі скажімо Дитина
з пісочком може ту букву там висипати на
папері е або з тіста дуже популярней в
нас той play-doh або Угу пластиелин
пластилін так званий але play-d воно
трошки інакше як пластилін Угу І от
дитина вже ту букву виліпить і дитина
Таким чином швидше запам'ятовує аніж
вона буде сидіти писати Тобто взагалі
канадських вчителів ті тих що в садочку
тепер кажуть що цілком викинути всі
папери але з вчителів ніхто не викидає я
поясню чому Бо в першому класі як дитина
приходи ходить до школи перший клас ще
не змінений на це він ще не є
орієнтований на playbas вони планують це
робити в майбутньому я не думаю що вони
знають точно як це робити поки що але
планують Отже то playbase тільки тільки
поки що тільки садочок так перш молодше
передшкілля до до сти років до Рокі
сташе дшкілля коли починається старше
передшкілля починається від пть ішість
років залежить бо в нас рахуєть 4 5 5ш
в нас рахується календарні роки от
скажімо дитина має 4тири роки в січні
або та дитина що буде мати в грудні То
вони будуть в одному класі Нема такого
що там до вересня місяця я не знаю як у
Україні тепер але тобто календарй в нас
від вересня до вересня так як було так і
є є ді ну є і пть років і а в перший
клас є якісь екзамени чи тести чи як
вони ну вступають як переводять з
садочка до першо
з цим автоматично з цими результатами
навчання да нема тестуван у нас просто
зараз тестування у всіх такого сач ні ні
Бо у нас тестування по тій простій
причині що там є мікрорайони йдуть або
вибирають ну це приватні школи
католицькі воничи приватні школи мережа
в них є на ви маєте на увазі в нас Вони
не є приватні ну вона є держа католицька
школа є тобто тільки в Онтаріо є
домовленість Це дуже цікавий факт коли
католицькі школи отримують ті самі
фінансування як і
і ну публічно ті муніципальні школи те
що є інші провінції того не мають то
тільки ми в онтаріоми має тільки Онтаріо
має таку привілею що це фактично
приватні школи але вони всі фінансуються
один до одного як Фіна і це Дві
паралельні системи існують А знаєте чому
Тому що коли от
проводять
сеensс як то населення перепис населення
Перепрошую перепис населення то вони
питаються значить ви живете там і там чи
ви підтримуєте католицьку систему Чи ви
і і коли ти вони ці всі дані не
ігнорують а збирають і тому що
надзвичайно велика кількість тих що
належить до і тих що посилають дітей в
католицькі школи тому вони не мають
права тобто не можуть закрити це тому що
відразу нарід би починав це тільки
католицький чи протестантській наприклад
християнський у тільки тільки като
тільки католицькі протестанти
греко-католики теж підходять
греко-католики власне туди підходять
православних туди не приймають вже
православ ви знаєте протестантів тим
більше не приймають Нічого собі ні тому
що вони розумієте
католицька освіта вони побудо Власне
вони собі вибороли таке право через те
що Рим дуже багато італійців тай взагалі
зрештою просто католики там прийшли
ще тільки коли
Канада встановлювалася і таке інше І
вони собі вибороли те право мати
особливо в онтарію ну це знову ж таки
інша тема але вона цікава Скажіть будь
ласка Скажіть будь ласка А скільки у вас
от в першому класі В нашому розуміння ну
це друга ступень Да коли вже в школу
приходять предметів є таке міжпредметне
розділення і скільки
от є чотири предмети у вас так але урок
ви проводите Як хочете комбінуєте
абсолютно ви ви ж по темах робите
виробити тему якусь Так значить е як
виглядає наш розклад є звичайно розклад
переважно це є блоками так от є блок
мовний є блок
а математика Social studies або Science
це
залежить не переважно не йде одночасно і
Social studies і S тобто математика і
англійська постійно а ці чергуються а ці
чергуються так крім того того ще є арт
Мистецтво це є обов'язкові фізкультура є
Так вони тепер більше на це уваги
приділяють І ото dpa так званей вони
навіть кожного дня півгодини там
танцювати і таке інше в садочку До речі
дуже цікава програма тепер називається
Creative movement Я вчила якраз цього
року половинку дня Тобто діти е трошки
фізкультурою займаються але попри то
вони більше танцюють
от координація рухів виробляється
отой Grow M Skills і таке інше А хто
вчить а хто вчить оцих людей проводить
ці уроки чи це От такі як ви проводите
Чи це спеціальні вчитель приходитьнікий
спеціальний вчитель той самий вчитель я
скажімо Я працювала з садочками я
подалася бо мене цікавила власне та
школа Я спочатку працювала в двох школах
по півдня півдня в одній школі з 30ма
дітьми других пів в іншій школі з
інакшими 30ма дітьми дуже важко було а
потім робиться так званий трансфер Коли
я можу до речі в Канаді з тим дуже легко
тому
що є різні ситуації конфлікт в колективі
щось там не спрацювалися з директором з
заучем так тоді людина Мені не
подобається та школа я ставлю себе на
Transfer list і тоді я можу шукати і
тоді значить борд
шкільний відділ освіти і
так виставляє позиції які є в інших
школах вільні де люди вже пішли на
пенсію або також роблять трансфер кудись
інше А і тоді скажімо я можу подаватися
в ту школу Таким чином Я перейшла в
школу про котру я давно мріяла я хотіла
тої школи але там було половинка Ось
цього Creative mov садочку я її
погодилася взяти тому що я з садочковими
дітьми працювала два роки я була
абсолютно з тими і дуже задоволена дуже
приємно було працювати з ним я не була
спеціально підготовлена тому що там не
треба бути там атлетом кидати на 50 м
гранату чи там якісь там ще якісь різні
речі в садочку дуже елементарне треба
дітей навчити от в нас є такі мішечки
beanbags так з фасолькою там чи з чим от
треба щоб дитина навчилась підкидати
ловити кидати до одне до одного і оці
вимоги до речі в вимогах щодо Е
cм як назива програми навчальної так
навчальної програми є оце щоби дитина як
в неї розвинуті оці Skills як fine Motor
Skills fine Motor то те що пишеться
рукою
дрібні дрібна моторика і та крупна не
знаю як ви кажете це по-українськи
крупна моторика не крупнарухо діяльні
рухова рухова діяльність оця рухова
діяльність чи дитина вміє скоординовано
там бігти йти І ви ставите ви не щоби
батьки не не думали що моя дитина
Господи вже ж кінчився той садочок а
воно ж ні одне ні друге ні Третє не може
зробити тому ставити що починає це
робити там чи вже абсолютно відповідає
всім вимогам і таке інше так що
спеціально вчителів на це тренованих
нема на фізкультуру вчать але
більше Розумієте це йде як Курси курси
під тобто я можу собі взяти додатковий
курс як вчитель фізкультури і
тоді подаватися десь в якусь школу вчити
фізкультуру але в нас нема такого
окремого предмету як переважно вчитель
фізкультури працює на дві-три школи от
Наш вчитель фізкультури що вона
є
вчителькою від четвертого до шостого
навіть від першого до скажімо до шостого
класу то вона має скажімо два дні три
дні в нашій школі і два дні в іншій
школігу бо в нас у вас п'ятиденка також
так о і так вона працює переважно
вчителі фізкультури і вчителі музики в
нас не є прив'язані хіба що Школа була
би дуже велика але вчителі музики теж
окремо як фізкультури так так вони мають
переважно їх Вони отримують свої
е власне школи там свої асайнменти на
роботу від від
своїх відділів так музичний відділ є в
борді окремо окреможть будь ласка у нас
було багато сперечань з приводу
інформатики в молодшій школі от чи є
вона в Вас чи вона якимось чином
присутня Можливо там в саєнсі чи в інших
ну предметах ну основи інформатики
мається на увазі вміння програмувати на
ну створювати якісь там презентації
Комп'ютер є це мусить бути ви знаєте в
теперішньому суспільстві це не не можна
того уникнути це мусить бути починаючи з
чотирьох років ніхто не каже дітям тим
сідати якісь речі робити але просто діти
миж ще Самі того не усвідомлюютьчи не
розуміємо не усвідомлюємо Наскільки в
тих дітей навіть от в нас якись там
останній своїх численних курсів брала і
розказував нам один пан котрий науково
цим займається Наскільки в дітей інакше
працює мозок вже наша генерація ми цього
не розуміємо а в них це вже майже
природно виходить і
тому це необхідно дати тим дітям в
Канаді Так ми Нам набагато легше але
навіть в онтарі порівняно з альбертою
Альберта багата провінція тому що вони
на нафті сидять так Онтаріо не є багата
провінція аж така Ну во досить Онтаріо
сама важлива не бідна Так але школам
ніхто нічого дуже так просто не роздає і
в нас комп'ютери часом бувають такі
старезні але але вони є так і є вже такі
цілі Значить ми купляємо з тими от з
такими лептопами не з таким старим як
мій з такими кращими трошки лептопами і
30 такий рухомий так званий клас так і
можна возити на колесах
і скажімо тоді Вчитель складає графік
Сьогодні я з 10 до 11ї працюю з тими
лептопами і дуже гарно працює програма
читання з маленькими дітьми от старші
діти скажімо шостий сьомий клас
приходять на півгодини до садочку і є
ота так зва вони називаються reading
баіс тобто такі друзі по читанні І от
там той Х хпчик чи дівчинка старший
сідає з тим малим і скажімо бере той
самий там чи лептоп навіть не лептоп
навіть можна скажімо навіть якщо нема
тих лептопів але звичайні маленькі
книжечки і вони разом читають то ті малі
діти так чекають тих старших дітей та то
щось надзвичайний
то скачуть до неба а то просте але з
комп'ютерами що робляться що вони вміють
от на приклад за молодшу школу що вони
мусять тут немає компютера Ні це не є я
почула Тобто це базовий скілс Я так
розумію баз що значить треба навчити
користуватися дітей маленьких
комп'ютером яким чином значить от
включити комп'ютер так логін переважно
ще маленькі діти в садочку Хоча є
абсолютно такі дуже як
тован просунуті що вони можуть собі самі
давати Раду і дають але переважно Там
хтось старший або вчитель сам там
включить компюте і тоді дитина може
вибирати собі програми бавитися От
бачите я принесла свій комп'ютер щоб вам
показати ті речі а нема wi-fi Є інтернет
подарунки Це в садочку вони мусять
навчитися включати виключати бавитися
навчальні ігри от ми маємо читання звуки
фонетика я вам Якраз хотіла показати
математика а нема таких статей що ну
статті пишуть журналісти що це некорисно
що це для здоров'я погано вже скільки
хвилин на день скільки хвилин на день
е взагалі так заохочують дітей більше
займатися спортом бути більш рохливими і
таке інше але люди всі свідомі що ми
йдемо до того щоби з комп'ютера от
скажімо Я мусила той свій Перепрошую
тарабанити комп'ютер бо я ж не імейли
перевірити ще щось а не скрізі же ж є
доступ до Просто ми йдемо до тої фази в
житті що без цього просто неможливо
собі дати раду і наші діти скажімо в
четвертому класі от я зараз прийду до
того що в четвертому
класі вони в розділі са показати то
прошу є Google Заходьте є Google Окей я
спробую тоді з в четвертому класі коли
вони роблять такий великий проект свій
по середньовічних часах середньовіччя
так Medieval times то вони роблять на
комп'ютері вони роблять PowerPoint
presentation і це вони повинні самі
абсолютно зробити четвертий клас
четвертий клас А у нас в
університетах Medal times але це ви
розумієте це на такому простенькому
рівні робиться тобто от дитина виходить
скажімо вчитель дає набір якихось там
сайтів де можна знайти про середньовіччя
є ж дитяче всяке різне є таке простеньке
Наприклад одна дитина робить яка була
зброя в середньовіччі хтось робить А яка
була їжа і оця дитина має в формі
в Я вчора в чоловіка питалася як це буде
pointф по-українськи по пунктах от по
пунктах розписати скажімо тут картинка
Так а з другої сторони в от по пунктах
розписати
Що в середньовіччі там люди їли ось таку
їжуд 4 прошу презентацію супроводом
таким от з таким супроводо ну тобто вони
це так вони це роблять на комп'ютері і
тоді значить вони це
презентують
і от маєте вже вам це дитина працює
по-перше дитина надзвичайно заангажована
до того тому що це цікаво робити І вони
це роблять а і плюс вчитель має за що
оцінити дитину значить оцінку за цю
презентацію також діти самі складають
може самі може вчитель визначає то
різні підходи Так але скажімо що вчитель
визначає Наприклад якщо вчитель визначає
то каже рівень чотири рівні є якщо на
четверто рівні значить дитина під час
презентації була відкрита гарно говорила
була
впевнена логічно було по побудована її
презентація і таке і тоді дитина дістає
level 4 так четвертий рівень Тобто це
найкраща оцінка в нас нема багато оцінок
чотири рівня Ось так достатньо для того
щоби абсолютно оцінити
дитину старшій школі по всій
школіel старша Перепрошую Старша школа
починає з сомого класу вони дістають
відсотки вони вже по відсотках дістають
свої оцінки так так і відсотки в них там
рахується досить складно обраховується
оцінка вже в старшій школі тому що їм
там дуже точно треба рахувати бо ця
оцінка в нас же ж діти нею не здають
ніяких вступних іспитів в університети і
таке і тому оцінка мусить бути дуже
точна бо це залежить для якоїсь дитини
скажімо стипендія якась там або залежить
для якоїсь дитини чи її приймуть в
туймус чи
ні такого розуміння як підкуп вчителів
ви розумієте що таке не може бути хоча
ви знаєте є таке що приходять і просять
діти часом я чула від своєї старшої
дочки вона вже закінчила університет
цього року то казала що часом просять що
от от випрошують оцінку але тут такий
дуже А як вас урок побудований Ви що
спочатку ретранслюйте якісь знання потім
вони їх момусять витворювати ну все ну
про молодшу школу поки говоримо можемо
по рівням поговорити Ну наприклад там Ну
якщо не садочок там беремо Вже шо шести
років Да бо тут ми саме цю реформу зараз
робимо
с років Да і 89 вони вас ну по якось
розрізнені по рівнях Чи це ну одна школа
з шостої до девятої це одна школаце це
називається primaryчо роки да перший
другий третій четвертий ні третій клас
тільки до третього четвертий шостийце
третій клас тобто до восьмої да років от
оця школа молодша в нас вважається
Скажіть будь ласка там класна урочна
система як побудована чи її немає
взагалі Чи це модуль скільки він триває
скажімо Переважно я Я почала Так я
почала була з хлин як воно побудовано
всередині переважно скажімо Якщо йде
мова про мову або про математику це
переважно годинні модулі але вчитель вже
на свій розсуд скажімо Сьогодні мені
треба півтора години З математикою бо
щось складніша Тема так і я собі беру
тих півтора години а з мовою там щось
Діти трошки дороблять завтра трошки
сьогодні
нема Тобто нема такого розділу по уроках
і оцих перерв по 5 хвилин нема В нас
такого бо воно не потрібне діти самі
собі встали просто розумієте коли
вчителі готові до того що дитина в класі
може встати угу звичайно себе культурно
повести чого вже вчать в садочку
починають вчити бо в садочку вчать як
себе поводити і трошки вчать як читати
ну не трошки переважно в садочку діти
вже повинні вміти читати на рівень е c
ABC я вам потім покажу по тих рівнях
а а вже потім якщо вчитель готовий що
дитина буде встане там походить собі по
класу перейдеться або ще щось але тоді
коли є час вчити вчитель замовкає Діти
розуміють що треба сісти і і слухати або
щось треба відповідати робити якусь
роботу от тоді вже легше тому вчителеві
самому вирішувати чи йому треба більше
часу на мову але формальний розклад
занять є скажімо спочатку там іде мова
хтось перший ставить собі математику то
вже також Бо вчителі є кожен з
своїми своїм іншим способом методом
навчання так І тому кожен вчитель
повинен виходити сам з себе також тобто
такого порядку уроку я як у нас немає да
Що там перевірка домашнього завдання там
потім викладання нової теми закріплення
часом таке є часом з математики таке є
скажімо от Діти прийшли так і ми робимо
перевірку домашнього завдання з того що
вчора що не зрозуміли значить обговорили
і таке інше але це перевірка домашнього
завдання це не
оцінюється Це просто якщо виникли
питання труднощі виникли питання може
бути таке
що якщо вчитель бачить що дитина не
робить постійно домашніх завдання тоді
значить
вчитель легко обійти цілий клас сказати
Ага ти зробив ти зробив Чому ти не
зробив а я не міг А я мав вчора танці Я
був дуже змучений був ще різні причини
але якщо вчитель він вже знає ту дитину
і він бачить що це не є якась Вагома
причина і то вже повторюється скажімо
тиждень Ну тоді треба контактувати з
батьками ясна річ
є різні способи також заохочення і
покарання дуже дієве я можу з вами
поділитися надзвичайним способом
називається
система
світлофора вулич Так система світлофора
значить як вона працює бо я це
спробувала зі своїми дітьми в мене був
дуже важкий клас і в Канаді що є зле в
нас є Сплит класи в мене був перший і
другий клас разом а в мене був було
десятеро дітей вісім дітей з першого
класу і 12 дітей з другого класу тобто
два класи Треба було вчити різні
програми і це було тяжко
мплек к вас класкомплек і це у місті в
місті нормально у це дуже
абсолютно вы отстали от
нас в Канаді дуже є багато проблем так
само і це до речі одна з тих проблем з
чим ми боремося але от скажімо Як тих
дітей тримати поки ти працюєш з другим
класом як той перший клас вони вже
скачуть по столах і тоді от дуже гарно в
мене працювала оця система
світлофора є скажімо Ось така штука
висить з кишеньками з кожним ім'ям в
мене 20 дітей в класі так на кожному
значить кишенька ім'я дитини
і такий твердий картон наполовину
поділений тут є червоне зелене і жовте
світло Так один круже жечок червоний
зелений знизу з другої сторони жовтий
е голосу не вистачить щоб кричати на
всіх і не потрібно тому що діти дітям це
це не помагає дітям то вже доведено
значить бачиш що дитина нечемно себе
веде раз підходиш до того жовте
світло А вони ж потім А я зараз поясню
чому вони цього не хочуть і чому вони
бояться бо якщо червоне світло значить
крім того значить тих світел діє система
компліментів тобто значить якщо гарно
дитина поводилася так якщо хтось товариш
прийшов і сказав ви знаєте пані
Перегінець а він мені сьогодні поміг
щось там з математики Я не зрозумів я
його спитався він мені поміг я тій
другій дитині ставлю комплімент за те що
він поміг таку коробочку на папірчику
пишу Там Івасик так кинула в коробочку
Івасик а той що прийшов і сказав
Петрусик кинула ім'я я там скрутила
Петрусик оту коробочку кинула і васик і
Петрусик вже дістали компліменти А як
вони дістали той тиждень червоне світло
то я тоді компліменти заберу геть угу а
чому заберу чому вони розстроєні Бо в
кінці тижня в п'ятницю В нас є
розігравка Так звана Тобто ми калатаємо
тут банку з тими компліментами і я
витягаю три імені і хто має відповідно
най велику кількість компліментів той
має більше шансів щось дістати а дістати
їм треба Ну олівчик для них це немає
значення ми часом собі думаємо Боже що ж
там Що ж то ті а тій дитині часом якийсь
олівчик нещасний дасиша воно щасливе як
не знати
що і от Якщо ж він дістане то червоне
світло і вони боються цього ви знаєте в
мене були такі дуже важкі діти просто
що ну Важкі
діти і для них навіть то червоне світло
і якщо вже червоне світло навіть жовте
світло - це вже попередження вони вже
присідають трошки часом ненадовго аж
дочекаються того червоного світла ну
червоне світло як бути
дуже постійним в тому в своїх власне
оцих методах і так далі І як ти він знає
що червоне світло це вже мамі вчитель
напише зауваження і мама це прочитає А
якщо він вирве сторінку або ще щось В
нас такого в Канаді нема таке до такого
діти не додумується але я знаю що в
Україні таке роблять то вчитель дзвонить
до мами і тоді ж біда біда А що ма
скільки скільки покарання різні в Канаді
звичайно не можна карати не можна бити
дітей абсолютно не можна але можна
відбирати те що дитина любить от я знаю
що деякі мої батьки то хтось забирав
скажімо той iPad на тиждень помагало
хтось забирав дитина страшенно любить
там хокей грати так а от не будеш два
місяці грати хокей бо ти якусь таку
дурницю зробив Що мусиш тепер терпіти
угу і оце цього вони бояться але оце
заохочення компліменти Вони ж приходять
додому вони скачуть Що ж я дістав
сьогодні комплімент угу а ось
компліменти зрозуміло що вони отримують
за Якийсь поступок і зрозуміло Світлофор
але скільки потрібно зауважень отримати
щоб компліментів вилучити з цієї коробки
Нади Ну якщо вже два зауваження от
скажімо дивіться зелене світло у всіх на
початку дня наприклад зелене світло у
всіх так тоді починає хтось там дуріти
дістає жовте світло відразу можна Ні
жовте світло я давала одне попередження
не працює жовте світло тоді як ще два
попередження після жовтого світла
значить раз попросила не помогло другий
раз без слів ви розумієте і це ж так
магічно працює Ти спокійно тихо підходиш
до тої цілої штуки з тими іменами і
просто вставляєш червоне світло вні а
і тишина в класі але це треба дуже якщо
вчитель так не не дотримується цього
якщо вони знають що А жовтий світ а то
для них немає значення тобто якщо вже
починати ту систему треба дуже
бути послідовним О дякую послідовним Так
так що ось ця штука щодо дисципліни в
класі помагає змалими з великими
звичайними Скажіть будь ласка от Пишуть
вони чим карандашами олівцями руч всю
початкову школу всю початкову школу десь
до класу каліграфії в нас нема ніхто не
має каліграфії то чому олівцями томущо
чому олівцями тому що можна витерти що
витерти помилку яку помилку будь-яку А
нащо Ну а чому нічо зумієте А я вам
заразжу не написати правильно Я вам
зараз скажу на дитину Ніщо так не діє
гірше ви подумайте про себе ви щось
написали і Хтось вам закреслив угу
переписати я як доросла людина Я не знаю
може хтось по-іншому це спри я як
доросла людина не те що я буду гніватися
або ще щось але це трошки так
неприємногу пригнічує А коли ж ти дасиш
тій дитині А там 25 помилок і все Ось
таке Червоне і зелене і перекреслене
скільки років вони
до що Зараз я вам скажу Ну до всю
початкову школу це 100% так до третього
класу мова йде про тоді коли починають
дітки писати тільки буквочки Тобто там
помилок Як таких бути не може це
неправильнона буквочка написана то есть
єсть елемент порівняння от я пишу ж тут
буквочки корявенькі корявенькі а тут на
тебі гарненька коли елемент порівняння
то якби само приємно там Тобто це не
помилки і тебе ніхто сварить не буде за
неправильно написано це Ну справа мо
можна домовитись з вчителями якщо
вчитель реально дитині черкає перекреслі
це впливає на психіку дитини Все одне а
коли кажуть помиляйтесь будь ласочка
тільки щоб ваші помилки рано чи пізно
перетворились в нормальне просто вона
час це теж грозить І це не не настільки
однозначно тому що час можна вас
послухати ще когось і сказати Так оліцем
це саме краще в світі Ну це ще вилами
поведіпи це ще невідомо
Так я я з вами абсолютно погоджуюсься то
я не можу сказати що це найкраще в світі
Просто
якщо олівцем навіть от скажімо дитина
пише бачите дитина написала три речення
тут раз перечитує своє то друге речення
щось му не сподобалося І що ж ти з
ручкою тоді зробиш Я ще раз кажу це
момент домовленості між
учас з батьками більше напевно ще треба
домовлятися ніж з учителями іноді
учителю приходиться допомогти декінтині
давай
осьпцте нічого вчитель може зупинитися
без проблеми нема
ніхто навіть якщо олівець зламався ви
знаєте то не є переважно вчитель має тих
кілька олівців якщо але просто ви
розумієте в чому справа що в початковій
школі вчитель Нема
такого нема такого от темпу що я вчитель
А ти учинь А тоталітар ну нема нема вони
вони це викинули
давно і
тоталітарної
абсолютно він тільки називається
по-англійськи це називається facilitator
Тобто фасилітатор ви вживаєте таке слово
тобто те ти направляєш ту дитину ти їй
помагаєш ти не є для того щоб там
покарати ту дитину або сказати от ти то
не знаєш А як ти міг то не запам'ятати
або ще щось
ні які осноні основні предмети Оце є
математика англійська Social studies що
включає географію і історію і і і sciнс
sнс включає е елементи фізики елементи
Природознавство Природознавство так так
так але там природознавство розумієте
скажімо от в другому класі Вони мають от
я вам Зараз скажу зараз я зараз дійду до
sсграіясторо в тому розмі Ну звичайно що
ні абсолютно не в тому роз і акт ну сенс
наука От бачите от Я вам зараз скажу
наприклад другий клас так Social studies
демо на 258 сторінку це в цьому
підручнику всі всі предмети так от цей
підручник це не є якийсь міністерський
документ або ще щось я вам поясню це
можна купити у вільному доступу Будь в
магазині будь-якому не в будь-якому а в
спеціалізованих магазинах але
а це просто як скажімо вчителі люблять
це купляти як додатковий матеріал до
своєї програми але тут є все те що вони
вчать скажімо в другому класі І от йдемо
258 сторінка зараз я
нема авторів тут кіль тут є абсолютно зі
тому що вони дуже багато вже це видавали
перевидавали і навіть не бачите вони
навіть не подають авторство немає
значени
ки називається Хто дбає про це хто автор
але якщо воно продається
cananни знають що це є абсолютно
відповідне до змісту того що вони
повинні знати що вони повинні навчитися
от значить йдемо от географія прошу
дуже Ну що ж тут в другому класі яка
може бути географія от вони вчаться
наприклад The Globe так про Глобус
вчаться от як він м'ячик не м'ячик А що
ж там є Екватор А які там ще є лінії А
для чого вони є а вони вчаться ще
сторони світу крім того і практично от
те про що Оксана каже компетентнісний
підхід значить практичне заняття ось
таке скажімо я в другому класі мала один
раз пригадую а вчилися Ми також про світ
про про мапу світу і сказати в мому
класі де є вікно а де є шафа А де є той
значить Та то є на півночі то на півдні
захід схід а дошка є на сході і таке
інше Угу і їм це цікаво Бо вони ж це Ну
це ж то що вони от можуть помацати і І
до чого доторкнутися і І про що
поговорити
далі після того як можна labeling The
Globe так як називаються речі на на
глобусі
Так це
детально але це ж це ж простеньке і те
що може континенти оце маєте
географію А нас в четвертому тому що в
нас за складне
все підхід нас континенти треба стільки
там по думати всім академікам що
написати дітям а не дати А це ж не
академіки повинні це от вчителі Хто
працюєсорі ці континенти Вони беруть
дощечки і складають Але ж це приватні
садочки дивіться а от знають і Зоряне
небо знають і континенти і карту Європи
і називають
столиці так виходить що почина
ро визначе Що таке столиця оце головне
для нас дати визначення що ж таке
столиця і
вже я в Україні вже 16 років не живу і
час але особливо після революції
гідності це ж кожен день з новин
починається українських еprсо T я
дивлюсь і от часом дивишся і думаєш Ну
що ж так закручувати його якось Ось так
щоби ніхто не зрозумів якщо це можна ось
такою пряменькою дорогою за д хвили
хвилини пройти і пояснити простими
словами і свою думку а ОЖ так же ж
закрутити і щоб тій дити Я тепер працюю
з дітьми тому що от те про що я говорила
вам що я мала Creative mov садочком Це
був минулий Минулого року мій са Тепер я
вчу англійська як друга мова для дітей
Ново прибули і дітей Я вчу тих що
приїжджають з України приїхала до мене
дівчинка з Києва надзвичайно мудра
дитина
Прекрасна але це з Києва вона має доступ
вона там і ще якусь французь купа
мовчила маса дітей приїжджають зі Львова
з
Тернополя з міських шкіл не з периферії
з міських шкіл Але часом е Ну я собі так
звикла ніби так пам'ятаю або може в мене
вже така
ностальгія за за минулим і таке інше Е
що думаю Ну це би дитина повинна була
знати скажімо в дити от дівчинка
приїхала тепер з з Тернополя вона з
шостого класу якісь такі прості речі я
кажу кажу Даринка ну як же ж ти це що ж
ви ж це не вчили Та ми вчили але і
дитина така що не не з таких слабеньких
дітей а сильна дитина не розуміє вчили
але не розуміють Просто ми все вчимо і
діти вчать але не розуміють і читання
Так ми читаємо Але ми не розуміємо О
бачите от тому А у вас техніку читання
перевіряють от швидкість в
голос швидкость не
перевіря швидкість не перевіря плутайте
техніку і швидкість техніка складається
з чотирьох компонентів і іноді даже
міністр коли виступав в неї за словом
техніка ішла ну скільки йде запис ви
можете назвати перерахувати щоб ну не
тільки нам була зрозуміла ця дискусія
Можливо хтось буде з фахівців дивитися
от техніка читання по чотирьох
параметрах перевіряється які це
параметри ну швидкість
виразність правильність розуміння
свідомість усвідомлення так скільки у
вас параметрів цих
перевіряється А ви знаєте для того щоби
по так дитини в початковій школі
визначають рівень от В нас іде від рівня
AA що є називається передчитальний
рівень Коли Дитина впізнає слова тільки
воно не вміє ще читати це перева
переважно в садочку то молодше
передшкілля
а дуже гарна є програма її правда Вона
платна а її треба купляти в на
американська програма Я хотіла вам
показати якась може що да мені е от
визначають рівень тої дитини скажімо на
кінець SK тобто перед першим класом
дитина повинна вміти читати на рівень C
це є тре четвертий рівень якщо брати до
уваги AA AA тоді йде a b and C B або C
Рівень це є прийнятний для того щоби
вступати в перший клас якщо ти не читаєш
на рівеньці це не означає що тебе не
приймуть ти автоматично йдеш нема
іспитів ти проходиш якісь параметри є
ось ми говорили
є тоді коли От коли вчитель перевіряє На
якому рівні дитина То він
перевіряє читання чи дитина не робить
помилок в читанні правильність по нашому
правильність і тоді
кохension розуміння усвідомлення того що
вона прочитала швидкості Дема а вони в
голос Да читають голос читають такло в
то
щос нічого страшно якщо перевіриться
швидкість але коли у нас був час коли
лише на неї звертали увагу через те
пішло в народі поняття техніка читання -
це швидкість вчителі ігнорували просто
тому що сиділи з секундомірами за очі
приходили і всі бідники тремтіли і мамка
питала скільки ж ти слів бідненька за
хвилину ой 60 слів а по програмі лише 40
А вчителька каже мало 60 80 Давай в
другому класі бо мене От У вас є така
норма встановлений такий обсяг от треба
прочитати в першому класі 30 слів в
другому там 50
швидкість ні швидкість враховується і це
взага дуже важливо і сьогодні в
голос 10 тому в нас і в школу беруть За
тестуванням де читання в нас теж не так
Що не прочитав і взяли А в нас не
прочитав і не взяли до цієї школи Хоча
ти тут живеш і Хоча ти можеш іти в цю
школу і навіть додаткові заняття брав в
цій школі а ти не підеш тому що ти не
читаєш то вже порушення то вже
перебільшення Своїх повноваже А так
пере поня
ти і навіть не заохочуємо бать дітей
своїх Нехай
ідутьча у міських Так я чула що у Львові
така сама історія івано-франківську така
сама бу ласка діалоги є на уроці от щоб
діти в групах працювали чи вони тільки
так на запитання вчителя відповідають в
групах є навіть от в
класі столи розкладають так залежить від
вчителя Кому як пасує тому що одному
вчитеві не подобається такий трошки
творчий без а інший в цьому абсолютно
знаходить велике задоволення бо бачить
що діти користають з того і є скажімо
якщо шість столиків поставлено разом і
діти працюють в групах тобто вони мають
якесь завдання і вони
працюють скажімо Навіть є ось таке от ви
питалися як побудований урок як
представлення нового матеріалу часом
може бути таке що от діти відкривають
скажімо якісь якусь нову главу
але Новий
Розділ перед тим скажімо в першому класі
вони вже трошки про це вчилися вони
трошки дістали поняття значить вони
відкривають оцей Новий Розділ і
вчителька питається от зараз в групах
спробуйте там є якихось там чотири
пункти так і ви зараз на чотири групи я
вас ділю і кожна група представляє свій
пункт що ви може що ви про це пам'ятаєте
що ви про це знаєте що ви про це можете
сказати Наприклад
вимірювання так в математиці розділ
вимірювання і от діти дається їм великий
папір для тої групи дається фломастери і
кажуть що ви можете про це сказати і
діти Там хтось намалював собі ногу так а
інший там на намалював цифри і от їхня
група п'ятеро чоловік давайте
представляйте дитині психологічно важко
вийти до дошки одна стоїть
як ми кажемо in Spotlight так всі увагу
звертають на тебе а тут група виходить і
є дитина та що встидається і вона вже
чується інакше а та що не встидається
взагалі супер чується і вони кажуть там
потрошки діляться між собою значить от Я
пам'ятаю що можна міряти відстань
кроками тому я намалював ногу а я
написав цифру бо я пам'ятаю що от є на
лінійці цифри написані можна лінійкою
міряти можна тобто те що діти памя от ко
Кожна група представляє і тоді значить
вчитель сумовує давайте от що Ви
навчилися і те що вони
представлять це вже по-свому навіть
можна
скажімо Візьміть Подивіться Що нового
тут є що ми будемо вчитися Як ви думаєте
про що ми будемо вчитися тепер а вони
тут побачили там щось Ну я не знаю як як
йде тема вимірювання термометр наприклад
а для мене це нове А чому термометр А
чому так має бути от я знаю про термо
таке тобто Оце є робота в групах діти
працюють між собою оце йде так званий
діалог а потім вчитель дає якусь свою
там ну версію чи нову інформацію до цієї
теми абсолютно так так вчитель дає але
оце Оте що він той вчитель витягнув ті
знання з тих дітей це є так
званий діагностичний assessment
diagnostic assessment тому що в нас є
вирізняють три типи оцінювання перше
оцінювання - це є діагностичне тобто на
початок введення нової теми ти повинен
зрозуміти На якому рівні твої діти
стоять що вони знають а може хтось вже
взагалі може там не знати в чому
вимірювати і всі всі речі там знає про
вимірювання і таке інше А може Взагалі
вони не знають де правильно поставити
лінійку А може хтось вже знає кути
вимірювати в другому класі є різне і
тому оцей діагностичний асесмент дає
можливість вчителеві бачити На якому
рівні твій клас є
те і тоді вже він далі визначає що як
рухатися і тоді вже представляється от
скажімо ви знаєте от дуже гарно працюють
на мій розсуд такі речі як щось там
намальовано на папері Так такі в нас є
великий Chart Paper щось ви там
намалюєте і все має бути візуальне тому
що без візуального Дитина нічого не
навчиться я тут бачила Отут на такий
qr-код на на підручнику цікавий це ми
його пікаємо
Заходимо на сайт і він там є в
електронному вигляді Чи це про Я думаю
ви знаєте що я Я ніколи це не робила Не
можу вам сказати спробуйте Оксано можна
про оцінювання перши діагностичне другий
то називається onlearning як діти
вчаться Тобто це відбувається в процесі
скажімо то саме вимірювання ви робите
такі діагностичні тести ви це
А це не йде на оцінку дитини скажімо в в
як то в та документ кумент ви тільки
дивитеся наскільки дитина це сприймає
Ага О щось дуже слабенько значить щось я
не то роблю Треба спробувати якийсь
інший метод як ті діти мають навчитися
може щось інше їм якось інше їм це
подати ту са Часом буває що зміст той
самий але якщо в іншій формі подати воно
цілком інакше
просто чи існують у вас такі форми як
контрольна
робота квиз так от так званий квиз це
короткий контрольної роботи так як я
пам'ятаю як я колись ми мали то нема
таких речей але квизис в ми говоримо про
Elementary school правда про молодшу
школугу ні є тести і є Тік тести - це
вже таке трошки довше Так це вже більше
скажімо з якоїсь там sс якщо це йде мова
про шостий клас є запитання дуже багато
є mulple multiple Choice відповідей
Тобто ти вибираєш відповідь А є питання
Що треба написати свою відповідь Але це
вже отоді той тест оце вже
є Як ви питалися про види оцінювання
оцей третій вид називається О то
називається assessment of
Learning оцінювання що дитина навчилася
вже в оцих три типи
асесментів Вони дуже популярні Ну не те
що популярні
Та так Воно має воно має сенс В принципі
тому що спочатку ви визначаєте тоді
дивитеся чи дитина це сприймає а тільки
в кінці можете і залежить який предмет
якє що це може бути або тест це може
бути або якийсь проект як дитина це
виконала От коли ми говорили про той
Medieval times як вони представили оцей
PowerPoint про е про про різні речі що
діялися в ті середньовічні часи і тоді
вже оця оцінка йде на документ скажіть
ще будь ласка
з приводу тем наскільки вони наскрізні
Ну от наприклад якщо ви там починаюте
тему континенти вчити Вона тільки в ну
в саєнсі сидить чи вона так само і на
мові
виролядаєтецей час ну і в ін На інших
уроках Так це воно в
принципі не завжди так вдається але в
ідеалі воно в принципі так би мало Так
побудовані е нашим вчителям як на
набагато досить легко працювати Тому що
є маса методичних розробок вже зроблені
для того щоб воно все переплітається
Якщо йде Скажімо так як ви кажете от
континенти тоді відповідно і в мові тоді
навіть можна дуже популярні Отакі є
journal entry що дитина в кінці тижня
описує що вона цікавого навчилася за цей
тиждень або у формі листа до батьків оце
надзвичайне це фантастика е я пригадую
Моя дитина менша Я цього не робила бо я
не мала четвертого класу вона була в
четвертому класі це скільки років а в
четвертому класі ой Скільки ж тобі було
року 10 років чекай зараз 13 10 років
так 10 років і от вона пише лист до мами
в кінці тижня це не кожен тиждень
робиться але і скажімо після якихось
цікавих речей от про той самий Medal
times бо це в четвертому класі також от
там форма листа це вже маєте мова так як
має виглядати формально лист і граматику
тут же ви собі там дивитеся як бо дітей
вчать писати До речі дітей вчать писати
есеї починаючи з другого-третього класу
в другому класі тебе вчать писати
параграф так абзац абзац Так вибачте
абзац
а і в третьому класі от тому Перепрошую
коли вже цей лист іде ти вже бачиш чи
дитина вміє виділити основну думку чи
відповідні підкріплюючи деталі дати до
того абзацу і так далі І от в тому листі
дитина пише я навчилася щоб в колись там
в Medieval times в середньовічні
часи дівчата щось там дівчатам не було
дозволено щось таке робити Мені це було
дуже цікаво ти знаєш мама мені це було
дуже цікаво От вам лист і дитина а
батьки як дістають таке вау це ж бомба
просто-напросто думають Ну та то ж моя
дитина ж працює так і дійсно воно щось
користає з того а потім ще взагалі
порівняння з теперішніми часами бо в той
самий коли вони вчаться про ті
середньовічні часи тоді ж порівнюють А
як в наші часи А чи в наші часи є
скажімо таке в тій країні що змінилося в
тій країні або скажімо ж як в нас в
середньовічні часи Як в нас це все
відбувалося на території нашої країни не
там в Римі і таке інше будь ласка
батьків взагалі от ви їх якось долучають
до процесу навчання дитини чи через
домашні завдання чи через Можливо там
вони мож можуть обирати якусь компоненту
чи проекту разом з дітьми ро домаш
завдання віно задається в дитячому
садочку ж його немає на знаєте в
дитячому садочку в принципі нема
домашнього завдання в принципі отак Щоби
сказати що я задав домашнє завдання його
треба виконати ні Хоча багато вчителів
батьки хочуть щоби ее вчителі деякі
задавали там щоб дитина читала але це не
є обов'язкове Тобто ти не оцінюєш того
ти просто дивишся Ага супер батьки
помагають вони хочуть тобто батьки самі
тягнуть вчителя Ага прошу чи можна
домашнє завдання щоб ми знали як з
дитиною працювати вдома от скажімо в
мене коли я вчила в садочок моє домашнє
завдання формально я не задавала аж так
багато писати в мене Я спочатку в одній
такій школі вчила е
дуже там багаті такі вимогливі батьки
були то вони хотіли щоб з дитиною там
писати бо там мами переважно мама не
працює Значить вона займається з дитиною
але так взагалі домашнє завдання основне
бо от в мене була така програма читання
Rus Kids Я попросила адміністрацію школи
адміністрація школи заплатила на клас це
коштувало 150 $ здається або 170 я не
пам'ятаю точно ціни і от та дитина
онлайн читає ті
книжки вона читає книжки і я можу як
вчитель тому що впід мене підписані всі
ті діти а можна підписувати аж до 36
дітей Я дивлюся скільки дитина прочи я
бачу всю цю інформацію тобто чи дитина
прочитала там дві книжечки чи вона вже
тиждень не заходила туди і тоді коли
батьки приходять на інтерв'ю тому що в
нас нема зборів я вже сказала а є
вчительські інтерв'ю з батьками Угу тому
що не можна при інших батьках говорити
про іншу дитину це приниження так так не
робиться То є порушення е прав дитини і
людини і тих батьків нещасних бо не всіх
діти на жаль зірки з неба хапають І от
тоді коли батьки кажуть от щось Моя
дитина чомусь не не може читати Я кажу
добре ви підписані на цю програму ми
заплатили Скільки разів ви читаєте на
день Чи ви читаєте бодай 30 хвилин чи
дитина читає бодай 30 хвилин на день і
тоді батьки кажуть ой я забув Ну я кажу
Ну Перепрошую трошки більше читайте
займайтеся і воно піде Ми в школі
працюємо але вдома Також потрібно
працювати дитина є обдаровані діти котрі
дадуть собі раду в будь-якій ситуації
але є діти котрим просто треба сидіти і
працювати але та система діти самі от
одна мама прийшла і казав він вже ж мене
мучить з тим що на айпеді мусить
півгодини читати Ну і мама мусить
дозволити му а для нього ж це заохочення
бо ж Може з тим айпедом посидіти
півгодини а ще плюс заохочення тому що
Як ти прочитаєш там а дві книжки і
правильно оте Про що ви говорили що
основне є коehнion тому що є діти навіть
в мене в садочку був хлопчик котрий
читав на рівні третього класу А
компрегншн було на рівні садочка бо
дитина ще не усвідомлювала ті складніші
речі просто не могла є діти що можуть А
є діти що не можуть тобто техніка от
власне чи техніка Я не знаю швидкість са
в нас це називається deкоing бо є
deкоing і є comprens оце є дві основна
от до чого ми прийшли два основних
параметри коли ми говоримо про
читання коли ти вмієш deкод
розшифровувати так тобто
читатиромі А коли ти можеш зрозумінням
читати це є дві речі різні і скажімо
декодинг є на рівні другого класу там на
рівеньди а а розуміння тільки на рівень
садочку тоді ти ду бачиш в чому треба як
дальше працювати чи третій дитині більше
Ну звичайно в Канаді є дуже багато
бібліотеки працюють є заохочення великі
від бібліотек А в тій програмі онлайн
діти можуть вони такого робота будують І
вони значить вони заохочені діставати ті
зірки за те що вони правильно там
відповідають на питання І вони ж тоді
того робота будують от до мене приїхав
хлопчик з цернопільської області села
має Напевно якісь LD то
називаєтьсяar
так ну в нас це трошки інакше Колись в
Україні називалося я пам'ятаю як я
вчилася ще просто вчитель поставив
клеймо на дитину і вже все і та дитина
як як той як баран ішов до до кінця і аж
не було то дитина може бути в інших
речах надзвичайно розвинута А він не
може
читати він не може читати і От коли
значить цей Вадим приїхав він відразу
по-перше шок інша країна таке таке таке
все інше І тут треба читати і Оце ж для
нього як я підписала його на той раз
Kids програму то Він приходив і мама
приходила потім на це інтерв'ю і казала
То ж мучить мене з тим вже стільки зірок
заробив стільки зірок вже робота може
збудувати вже космічний корабель бо їм
за то що таке заохочення знаєте і воно
тягне ту дитину і він часом автоматично
але тоді я можу все рівно бачити
наскільки та дитина чи так чи інакше як
воно 50 разів побачить то слово і мусить
прочитати А ще там є така опція що можна
натиснути щоб чути вимову правильну це
вже англійська як друга мова то воно ж
тоді Ну сенс має для тої дитини і Він
рухається і я от за буквально за той рік
я надзвичайно ним задоволена тому що
дуже сильно посунувся бо я ж маю
можливість перевірити його читання в
українській мові український він
страшенно вже дитина четвертий клас А ви
вчите дітей Україну мовних Я вчу дітей
україномовних так так і предмети
викладаються українською мовию лише
англійська Ніні ні предмети всі
англійською мовою але вони до мене
приходять на частину коли скажімо в
їхньому тобто як діти що приїжджають ESL
English is a Second language так learner
вони приходять в нормальний клас так
скажімо от в нас В католицькій школі
вони прийшли в нормальний клас але тому
що з коли йде мовний блок в класі
їхньому вони не можуть в цьому брати
участь бо їхня мова не дозволяє це
робити так з математики ще часом хоча
наша Математика є дуже побудована на на
мові там маса описування але скажімо
коли йде мовний блок він приходить до
мене в клас бо я є вчитель англійської
як другої мови і я тоді з ним або пробую
трошки математики з математикою ми
працюємо
або я вчу його такі читати
писати англійською так А тим часом інший
частина класу а його клас вони Вони
працюють вони собі працюють в свому
класі так вони вчать собі мову а він
приходить до мене на той час на той
момент бо до мене як до вчителя
англійського офіційні так звані офіційні
підручники чи існують у вас офіційні п
визначені кимось не знаю міністерством
ви маєте на увазі Я не знаю наше
Міністерство бо на федеральному рівні в
нас звичайно нема нічого а на
провінційному є свої Міністерство
підручників
визначених Ну вони існують в принципі
але Щоби сказати тільки що ти не маєш
права робити нічого іншого тільки це ні
от скажімо математика - Це в нас а
неelsн так дуже багато вчителів до речі
нарікають на цю програму але в принципі
вона є краща з того що що що є що було
отдивіться як вона побудована бачите Оце
є вчити книжка для вчителя тут пише
Teachers resource так і тут є розділи і
ось тут другий клас
А це є всі буквально по маленьких
книжечках по розділах все що вони вчать
протягом року починаючи від цифри один і
до цифри не пам'ятаю ятратим остання
цифра і тут бачите описано що з тими
дітьми можна робити Оце є такий
методичний а в дитини на парті що лежить
а в дитини на парті до другого класу в
них є така тільки так звана Workbook
робочий зошит але це не зошит воно
виглядає приблизно Ось так тої книжки
нема в другому класі нема в третьому вже
з'являється а в другому нема в другому
вони більше ось так таке більш так
Практично все
робить але але дуже багато
вчителів вважаючи що діти відстають з
математики для вчителя для вчителя для
вчителя оце важливо вчителя
нас програма одне а ми її виконуємо
використовують ось цей
jumpме це є програма побудована на
таких вироблення таких навичок що до
автоматизму доходить різні речі
додавання віднімання такий тренажор
Можна сказати так от бачите От коли йде
Round to the near так округлю до
найближчих до найближчого десятка і тут
вже буквально маса тих вправ іде і воно
є легке чим діти Чому діти люблять цю
вправу бо та дитина котра слабенька і
котра скажімо є діти от воно дивиться на
тебе а воно тебе не розуміє чи в
українській мові чи в англійській чи
будь-якій мові тобто рівень також свого
роду в нас бачите це ще і так тема
розмови коли визначають need
такіти що мають оці Learning
disabilities в Канаді нема дурних дітей
от нема є діти що мають спеціальні не
встигаючих нема є діти зі спеціальними
потребами є діти ті що трошки слабші
академічно так що вони мають оцінку всі
бо вони більше не можуть але тоді
вчитель більше на них
націлений вся система освіти я би
сказала більше націлена на на тих дітей
щоби всіх привести не на тих мудрих що
от як я пригадую собі от вчитель стоїть
так В мене в класі 30 дітей в Україні
було там скажімо ну в англійській трошки
півгрупи і півгрупи але от більше
працювалося тих троє сприймає ти з ними
працюєш задоволення страшне А ті всі
бідні сидять і і Очи очима кліпають і
нічого не розуміють то в Канаді навпаки
значить тим дітям е сильнішим так вони
можуть працювати індивідуально ті діти
вони можуть працювати самі тільки
вчитель може тільки їх трошечки
націлювати туда-сюда вони собі дадуть
Раду і підуть може ще дальше їм навіть
не треба того безкінечно повто а Робота
вчителя більш націлена на тих слабших
дітей і ти з ними працюєш І оцей jumме
дитина чим задоволена бо воно відчуває
що воно може це зробити і це є легше і
коли воно 150 разів зробить ті самі речі
воно на 151
навчиться тяжче трошки доходить але тому
що всі по-іншому сприймають різні речі
так що оцей jмпмет тому про визначені
підручники ну В нас в Онтаріо ніби
математику вчаться по
нелсо приватні школи трошки інакше вони
мають свої програми вони можуть вони не
обмежені абсолютно чому так звані ті
державні або фінансовані державою школи
трошки обмежені через те що в в третьому
в шостому і в дев'ятому класах в нас є
так званий eqao тест це є тест по
всій по всій Канаді котрий визначає
рівень математики і мови в
дітей це той тест пишеться цілий тиждень
а і це оцінюється не дитина а оцінюється
школа і оцей тест потім дає вони роблять
статистику кожній дитині правда
присилають на якому рівні я вам вже
казала що оцінювання Там йде level One 2
3 4 чи дитина
є але це дуже точно знову ж таки
обраховується це все
автоматично читання на такому рівні
розуміння тому що в нас мова скажімо от
Як ви подивитеся на наш на наше
свідоцтво в кінці
року коли мова в нас оцінюються такі
параметри читання
писання усне мовлення і іia іia також
відноситься до мови що відноситься до
іia коли дитина вміє застосувати мову
практично тобто скажімо якщо в
четвертому там чи чи в другому класі
вони якісь роблять оголошення Так в мене
пропав песик а усні то есть письмові
невеличкі твори мається на увазі це не
твори оце суто мідіа як вони це
висловлювання висловлювання можливо це
так А як вони це вміють подати зв'язний
текст Це трошки інше практичні роботи да
оголо оголошення
реклами як вони орієнтуються в тих на
сайт там чи в газету Ну такі так так от
Ось такі речі ото в нас коли йде мова
про про власне про мову про лендж так
Отакі життєві речі значить вони
оцінюються в
мідіати і знову ж таки вернуся до своєї
дитини в нас було День пам'яті воїна що
в листопаді відбувається і вчителька
надзвичайно цікавий проект
придумала щоб намалювати значить мак і
просто написати кілька
слів Чому ми повинні поважати тих воїнів
І от я як ти думаєш кожна дитина і перед
тим вони звичайно вчилися там читали
багато маса
книжок робили всякі дослідження свої
щось там на комп'ютері якусь інформацію
шукали і в кінці от вони такі на
листочку паперу просто треба було той
поустер так званий виготовити маленький
от формат десь ось такий так і от Моя
дитина ж змушувала каже дивися я це
зробила і каже ми смети італійка
Вчителька сказала що ми маємо на
автобусних зупинках причепити ось ці і я
з нею мусила їхати бо ж треба дитину
підтримати і ми на всіх тих зупинках
казали що от як то гарно що наші воїни
віддали за нас своє життя а то ж знаєте
в Канаді йде мова ще про першу які ми
вдячні за то чому як ми повинні про це
пам'ятати і дякувати І от ми на чотирьох
біля нас там чи п'яти зупинках виставили
Ось такі її постери бо мимей сказала як
ти вмієш комунікувати інформацію до
інших от скажімо Ось таким Я до речі
Славі оці ну стрижньові такі ну навич
там патріотизм як вони виховуються
вміння комунікувати воно якось
оцінюється на якомусь рівні От наприклад
на кін ну в сингапурі наприклад вони
виставлені що ти мусиш там на кінці
початкової школи Там знати про Сингапур
що ти мусиш там ну тут принципі так так
само так так так само В Канаді є вони
починають Я думаю з другого класу це є в
в межах оцих Social studies географії
вони вчаться та також повинні знати там
назви всіх провінцій це вже на кінець
четвертого класу повинні знати
скажімо назви всіх міст основних
провінційних так повинні знати ще щось
там про про свою
провінцію так про Онтаріо Який в нас
прапор чому в нас клиновий листочок на
прапорі звідки це
прийшло оцінювання це знову ж таки йде в
межах Social Stud щоби скажімо ко
виділити що цим визначається
патріотизм Канада країна імігрантія Я
навіть не знаю Україна - це зовсім
інакше
які От такі
стрижньві ну як вони називається ідеї да
які закладаються по всіх предметах ну
Протягом навчання Може якось цей рівень
ну крім вмінь таких скажімо академічних
там читати писати
рахувати знати там назви провінції от
які навички для життя там вони для життя
Ну перше це починаючи з садочка
починаючи з садочка це настільки
серйозно дітям вкладається в голови
проблема
сміття що діти приходять додому дослівно
і це я знаю від наших батьків імігрантів
приходять ви знаєте приїжджають там з
України чи хтось там з Росії не знати
звідки сміття та й сміття А це ж діти
мордують батьків Потім ну як же ж ти
можеш скажімо якийсь там пластик чи шкло
викинути там де має бути рейкл там де
має бути папір це не може йти в одне
сміття і діти приходять і кажуть так А
де наше відро на рейклин бо пані така і
така в школі сказала що рейкл має йти в
це сміття а таке звичайне сміття має
окреме сміттяце така екологічна грамота
просто на екологічна гра це є просто
настільки
ЗАО починаючи з садочка є маса книжок і
от я би вам радила бо я вже стикнулася в
Києві
з сумно трошки але я розумію чому то
неможливо так перескочити всі речі
відразу щоб все було не знати як 20 ро
ну так хотілося б щоб скоріше
але починаючи з садочка я би казала що
от скажімо освітянам працювати з тими
авторами книжечок для дітей бо в садочку
це робиться тільки через книжечки от
Вчитель читає Ти ж не можеш починати от
діти нам треба то і то так є в нас дуже
цікава така програма називається
reduce reuse recycle І от хтось там
написав книжечку Так що то називає що
означає - це є зменшити reuse вживай
знову і cйкл переробити Оце є програма
3r вона вже діє в Канаді Ну не знаю вже
довший час так і
а все направлене от книжечка починається
введення для теми такої для дітей в
садочку Michael recycle книжечка така Я
пам'ятаю так той Майкл що і значить
книжечка побудована на тому ти читаєш Що
він приїхав в якесь місто а там люди
викидали сміття і то сміття їм
позавалюва ло хати і в кінці всі були
дуже розстроєні Що ж робити а потім
маichкл recйle з'явився І каже люди Ну
давайте ж лопати брати в руки і ми самі
це розчистимо і вони це розчистили і
такі почали надзвичайні квіти рости і
всі такі щасливі як то класно і вони
після того діти ходять і вже той маichкл
recйкle без кінця і краю тільки про це
говорить як це добре що має пові що має
дихати все угу а тоді значить скажімо
вже говорячи про цю тему ЖЖ е-е в
першому або в другому класі здається
коли йде мова про воду так ми вчимося
про воду як вода потрібна як то круго
колообіг води коло колообіг води
наскільки вода потрібна як її треба
тримати чистою чому не не можна нічого
кидати в сміття і так далі І тоді є одне
з таких домашніх завдань дитина
приходить і має наприклад табличка так і
в табличці скільки
е В мене ввечері разів спустили туалет
так скільки в мене води використали там
на ще щось так На шеб от приблизно так
або якісь такі практичне ну такі речі і
тоді дитина вчиться і тоді ж приходить
додому Каже мама що ж ти чистиш зуби а
вода тече Не можна так треба закручувати
не у
львовігу ну є Та я знаю що дехто вже
напевно що це з цим працює і і але
просто щоб цим дітям котрі власне
початкова школа цих дітей ще можна
навчити бо ті вже що старші ї вже трошки
їм якщо але оцим маленьким починаючи з
садочка починаючи з першого класу для
них це цікаво і тоді ж вони ходять а
проект зробити таке що в школі Щось вони
таке Ну не знаю якийсь там плакат
зробили всі разом щось там написали що
вважай на природу або знову ж таки в
маленьких був такий Перший клас здиється
проект вимикай світло Так і вони всі по
цілій школі біля вимикачів поставили
вимикай світло не залишай світло як ідеш
Кудись і для них це цікаво залишилось
максимум 20 хвилин може ну В кого є
запитання дайте Скажіть будь ласка чи
знаєте ви загальне навантаження
годин навчальних на
дитину в Канаді є визначена кількість
годин скільки уроків наш день я вам
скажу Так значить шкільний день
починається 8:30 Угу закінчується о 3й о
15 так о 15 початко всіх школах крім
High School бо ті що починаючи з детого
по 12-й клас в них день коротший в них
там вже йде тільки чотири
предмети профільні профільні ну Навіть
так більш-менш а відпочивають вони
скільки в них от в нас канікули час два
місяці Ми вчимося Я буквально закінчила
шкільний рік на в нас був останній pa
Day то називається Professional Activity
Day і в п'ятницю я вже приїхала тобто
накілітні канікули місяці літні канікули
два місяці зимою нас тільки зимою і
літом є канікули То все А зимою кіки вас
а зимою канікул два тижні приблизно
Навіть трошки менше семест так А скажіть
будь ласка діти в молодшій школі от з 8
до
15:00 перший клас скажімо ість років
вони там сплять чи є якісь прогулянки Чи
це весь час оцей такий ну освітній
простір значить 8:30 якщо вони починають
так просто ви розумієте Нема
такого Ну все Так собі Так як у Львові
кажуть ляньксом так спокійно нема
ніякого тиску Тобто ти починаєш там
календар зробили з дітьми дуже діти
багато вчаться коли вони роблять
говорять про погоду малюють собі що
сьогодні сонячний день там вчаться
висловлюватися це в молодшій школі дуже
популярно гімн співають гі о гімн це
обов'язково так у всіх канадських школах
починається перше це йде загальношкільне
оголошення починається гімн В
католицькій школі молитва обов'язково
гімн молитва а тоді вже те що
відбувається протягом дня Там директор
чи зауч оголошує так що має відбуватися
протягом дня тоді триває перша перерва
До першої перерви перша перерва скажімо
ми починали 8:30 то перша перерва в нас
була в
10:15 загальна загальна перерва це
загальна перерва вона триває 15 хвилин
до
10:30гу тоді від 10:30 і
до 11 залежить Було колись в нас 11:30
тоді трошки змістили через автобуси бо в
нас діти всі доїжджають автобусами
11:15 починається годинна перерва на
ланч так від 11:15 до
12:15 і в цій перерві 20
хвилин перших є тоді коли діти їдять це
є ланчтайм Угу 20 хвилин після 20 хвилин
дзвенить дзвоник і діти мусять виходити
на вулицю на вулицю виходять всі угу це
є час вчителя коли він має відпочити і
з'їсти свій ла з ді з дітьми чергові
вчителі вчителі чергові на перерві тому
складається дуже великий справді
головний біль для директора тому що
треба все узгодити тому що вчителі не
можуть мати більше ніж
а-а здається 45 хвилин
чергувань я непевна 45 або щось таке 45
Ні більше годину тому що 20 20 і 15 так
40 Ну майже до години часу 45 хвилин
десь 45-50 хвилин вчитель має на тиждень
бути черговий кожен якщо хтось є ще така
таке поняття як профспілка вчителів
вчителі деякі люлять поняття є проспілки
Нема поняття ви знаєте є дуже багато
позитиву і негативу у тій проспілці Так
що це таке дуже часом захищає проспілка
вчителів там де їх не треба захистити
там де треба не захищає але то вже Інше
питання Отже має бути дуже чітко кожен
вчитель має отри директор за це
переживає бо він дістане на горіх якщо
він не дотри повітря рухливі ігри
вчитель черговий він просто спостерігає
за дрі спостерігає наві це початкова
школа це початкова школа Так навіть в
початковій школі
в в садочку в садочку так само вчитель
не зобов'язаний їх
розважати якщо є дитячі площадки діти
собі бавляться вони самі собі
організуються вчитель спостерігає не
зобов'язаний і тоді ще питання вже не
знаю а тоді Перепрошую я скінчу з
розкладом значить в 12:15 закінчується
оця годинна перерва і тоді продовжується
наступний блок до другої після обідньої
перерви і друга та післяобідня перерва
починається
в
другій
а 2:20
здається триває до
другої 45 чи скільки там 15 хвилин Угу
15 хвилин і тоді вже до кінця дня після
перерви тобто є тільки дві малі перерви
по 15 хвилин і одна година перерви то це
школа повного дня школа повного дня Так
а от Можна запитання яким чином
організоване середовище в початковій
школі ви казали там є рекреації чи є
якесь Ну обов'язкове обладнання по
класах наприклад да з яким діти працюють
чи кожен вчитель це робить так як це
зручно для його методично кожен вчитель
переважно робить це так Як зручно йому
але скажімо коли мова йде про перший і
другий клас обов'язково в класі є крісло
гойдалка в більшості Ну не обов'язково
але в більшості крісло гойдалка і
невеличкий килим де діти можуть сісти і
Вчитель
читає бо
є це дуже заохочується щоби вчитель
читав ось цю там якихось в кінці дня
переважно коли вже діти втомлені так
дуже цікаво уважно тому що якщо діти
побачать вчителя який читає читає
зацікавлена то вони захочуть читати дічи
і це до речі ось це працює не тільки для
молодшої школи для всіх вчителів
якщоце в Канаді це називається R Mod ти
повинен свої Своєю поведінкою
демонструвати те що ти хочеш навчити тих
дітей інакше во буде працювати мене
питання іноземно мо коли вона починає
вчити в різних провінціях по-різному в в
Онтаріо французька починається з першого
класу як це виглядає виглядає скажу вам
так чесно
е-е не дуже гарно не дуже гарно
півгодини діти до восьмого класу
доходять дуже слабенько говорять
по-французьки півгодини на тиждень
півгодини на день вони мають 30 хвилин
на день щоденно щоденно Так це дуже коли
вони починаютьпи коли вони починають
писати починаючи з третього класу три
рази на годині там не раніше Т з треть
вони лідери якось там вчать лідери вчать
так вони їх повинні писати чи просто
клеїти чи
абсолютно то є вже на розсуд вчителя
можуть писати можуть копіювати тому що
скажімо дитина добре вчиться також як
копіює тежі тобтопише може trй робити
так від там пунктиром Вони там пишуть по
цьому
переважно але в нас таки знову ж таки є
школи в котрих і французька в нашому
випадку французька є
як то називається imion програма або
frch extended French imion тоді коли
дитина занурюється цілком так і це є з
першого класу і вони цілком тільки
по-французькій це все англійська там
допускається тільки в четверто в п'ятому
класі і тільки два предмети англійської
все решта французька мова Мене цікавить
ці але от це От так званий
Cor коли вони мають вводять другу
іноземну мову це є з першого
класу по 30 хвилин а є вчителі що
надзвичайно це роблять не завжди то я
вже так трошки грубше сказала що діти не
можуть говорити але є вчителі котрі дуже
гарно це провадять і тільки французька
йде тільки французька вони там співають
також і танцюють чи тільки і танцюють і
співають а в третьому класі що таке
письмо в третьому класі що вони роблять
на письміже в іноземній мові Да в
іноземній не ж так дуже багато але
пишуть знову ж таки залежить від рівня
дітей бо тоді вже пробується підійти до
дітей де ці
я поясню чому таке Ну прискіпливе
запитання у нас зараз так само точиться
дискусія у нас програма молодшої школи
Передбачає Що в першому класі діти
починають відтворювати
графічні ну
літерислово сполученняслово сполучення
раніше ніж їх навчать ставити запитання
один одному тути Як тебе звати І автор
програми наполягає що це саме так мусить
ну бу Ні я я мушу до комп'ютера підійти
я вам дуже хочу показати Якщо Вас
цікавить англійська Як навчання чи
взагалі
будьякараз
тодіноземна
мова так чи не відчувається от якогось
негативного ставлення до тих діток Тим
більше що ви працюєте ну зокрема з
українськими
дітьми вони якись такий трошки відчуває
рокицекає само по собі бо вже наскільки
наскільки вже демократичне і таке
тоталітарне суспільство чи все-таки
вчителі якось цього вчать вчителі ви
знаєте але от відразу Такі от ставати
так от натурально їжаки Ну як батьки так
і от власнеце ж приносять сімей і тоді
приходиться пригладжувати і казати
хлопець приїхав тут він трошки такий
трошки девакуватий соціально і і в
академічному плані але він приїхав і
почав от пробуй то би всякими
українськими дурними словами і він два
рази вчитель але ви розумієте що тут в
нас в Канаді діє така система що
директор має право зробити тут батьків
два дні дитина не приходить до школи
Мене не цікавить Що ти робиш з тою
дитиною ти повинен з нею працюватигу не
карати бо якщо ти будеш карати так що
дитина буде це відчувати До речі Вчитель
повинен якщо бачить що дитина прийшла з
якимось повідомити відповідну службу
спочатку до директора бо це
єuse це є знущання над дитиною тобто не
можна це але іншими способами працюй з
дитиною і пояснюй що так не можна робити
І от вже рік минув для допомоги а не для
биття руки і ноги до себе не можеш і
дуже нам помагає поліцейський бо поліцаї
наші приходять дуже такий гарний в нас є
офіс приходить і розказує ти можеш ти
повинен трактувати когось так як щоб
пратували
і і це дуже великий пункт в навчальній
програмі дуже велики